[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me sens comme un malaise qui s'est
installé là comment prendre la parole
après sa faute il l'a pas le malaise on
peut sentir entend maintenant se sont
cependant déroulées comme les experts en
la matière on attire cinématographique
c'est le malaise s'installe déconner
c'est de parler de jouissance parler de
sexualité difficile mais la limite quand
on parle de sexualité
on peut toujours se référer à des
chiffres à des catégories à des
disciplines scientifiques
anthropologique sociologique
quand on parle de jouissance en ce
moment il n'y a aucune science et oblin
critères objectifs
c'est pour ça qu'on commence avec un son
j'aurais pu vous montrer une image mais
l'image aurait d'emblée dévier la
discussion vers la sexualité la
jouissance jeudi terme à dessin est un
terme qu'on en voit très peu ailleurs
ces ions de le dire quand on y jouissant
ce simple comme comme l'y moment dix ans
des redites un gamin comme une
transgression qui rougirait d'elle-même
jouissance la voile se faire comme si
comme si on assume et pas le pont
lui-même n'est sûr mais pas seulement
d'ailleurs jeudi le terme mais la
jouissance l inverse du terme c'est pas
une fin qui va nous conduire jusqu'au
terme
la jouissance est l'art de mener le
chemin jusqu'au terme c'est l'art
d'avoir du plaisir que de quel plaisir
s'agit-il étymologiquement là je me sens
un sens juridique ont joui d'une chose
que l'on possède
c'est une dimension matérielle quand on
est propriétaire d'un objet prenons une
voiture sa propriétaire d'une voiture
vous pouvez jouir de ce bien comme bon
vous semble
une fois que vous avez acheté la voiture
vous pouvez la conduire
vous pouvez la repeindre vous pouvez en
faire ce que vous voulez vous pouvez la
détruire la jouissance et son limites
avec les critères simplement celui de la
propriété envoyé que ça pose déjà un
problème celui de cette pole est
jouissance en terme de possession c'est
que progressivement le sens même de
jouissance s'est déplacé vers un sens
sexuel barre dans le centre dans
sexualité il ya pas de possession voilà
en tout cas pas en termes de propriété
la possession peut être fantasmes et on
ne possède pas l'objet la personne en
porte l'idée avec laquelle on décide de
jouer vous décidez pas vraiment
d'ailleurs avec laquelle la jouissance
advient et quand le terme s'est déplacée
vers le la dimension sexuelle ça arrive
en même temps qu'un autre glissement de
sens et celui de la consommation
aujourd'hui il faut jouer un impératif à
la jouissance
ça vient pas si ancien l'appel à jouir
sans entrave une revendication politique
qui s'inscrivait dans un contexte
particulier faisait de la jouissance un
impératif une demande un ordre presque
jouissait alors jouissez sans entrave
jouissait de tout à tout prix et le plus
possible or la jouissance d'un comprise
au contraire les gens n'est pas un
impératif quand on ordonne jour rien
n'est rien même le n'éloigne davantage à
la jouissance que l'ordre de jouir c'est
une affaire de volonté suffit pas de
vouloir jouer pour jouir serait
davantage une affaire de caractère
mais notre problème est celui de l'idée
même de consommation lorsqu'on consomme
quelque chose pour en jouir consommer
implique une absorption tonale de
l'objet consommer un objet implique la
fin de cet objet en l'ajustant semaine
fin d'année dévorante
quand elle est extrêmement puissante ne
consomme pas l'objet pour en parler en
tout cas le réduit pas à néant la
jouissance ray l'art de prendre du
plaisir à quelque chose en ménageant ce
plaisir est un jeu extrêmement subtile
infiniment délicat entre le désir d'une
grande hui vers la jouissance faire un
plaisir ultime est la distance maintenu
entretenu avec ce qui nous fait jouir la
jouissance aurait fait rare presque un
art de vivre en tout cas une manière qui
s'apprend de composer avec le plaisir et
ce plaisir donc n'est ni celui d'un
impératif initiale d'une consommation
il faut distinguer ici plaisir de désire
prendre du plaisir à quelque chose est
une chose désirer une chose est encore
différent lorsqu'on désire celle inverse
de la consommation ne désire que ce
qu'on n'a pas le désir implique du monde
si j'ai un objet devant moi je peux
certes avoir du désir pour lui mais une
fois que je les consommer une fois que
j'en ai fait ce que je voulais le désir
mais très intéressant le désir lui même
a besoin de ce qu'il n'est pas pour
exister
le désir et 7 c'est comme cette
direction on doit suivre pour atteindre
ce que nous voulons ce qui nous manque
mais dès que le manque à combler le
désir s'efface comment faire alors pour
à l'avoir entretenir le désir tout en
jouissant puisqu'il s'agit quand même de
jouir et par jouissance ici il faut bien
entendre si c'est un désir c'est plus
qu'un plaisir à dire que prendre du
plaisir à quelque chose n'est pas une
forme jouissance les jouisseurs c'est
celui qui prend du plaisir quand il a du
plaisir le plaisir d'avoir du plaisir
facile à dire c'est extrêmement
difficile à faire parce que déjà on le
dessine paris suffit pas de vouloir
prendre du plaisir à quelque chose pour
y parvenir qu'est ce qui en nous prend
du plaisir à quelque chose c'est pas la
volonté c'est pas l'intelligence c'est
pas simplement le corps sinon on serait
tous égaux face à la jouissance arsenal
bien albert camus le philosophe disait
il faut une rare vocation pour être à
jouer
ça veut dire deux choses qu'il faudra
rogations pour la tranche jouisseur
premièrement que c'est une vraie
jouissance est une affaire de caractère
au regard des jouisseurs caractère alors
ça veut pas dire qu'on ne jouissent à
dire qu'on peut le devenir de caractère
c'est la rencontre entre de l'inné et
l'acquis c'est ce dont nous sommes faits
et ce que nous faisons de nous mêmes par
les rencontres que nous faisons la bonne
nouvelle ça veut dire que la jouissance
peut s'apprendre mais aussi 7,7 cette
inégalité de fait mais bien loin du
droit aussi même si bien que le droit
peut hélas pour résorber les inégalités
mais en termes de jouissance comment
faire parce qu'encore une fois la
différence de la sexualité c'est pour ça
que je partage cette idée la jouissance
et quelque chose d'infiniment subjectif
et d'un partageable c'est pourquoi il
est si difficile de parler de la
sexualité mais il est quasiment
impossible
inaudible inouïe de parler de la
jouissance sa part mm superflu pourquoi
en parler pourquoi en parler
d'ailleurs failli des très peu fait il
ya très peu de références d'études sur
la jouissance les textes on trouve les
questions de jouissance sont rares et
explique nous sommes très peu les choses
et comme un impensé qui est passionnant
justement pour la pensée de voir mais
qu'est ce qui se joue dans ce terme là
de jouer dans son mot de jouissance dans
cet acte de jouissance qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui se joue
qu'est-ce-qui que recèle ce terme qui
explique la réticence que nous avons en
parler c'est pas simplement un tabou
social de une question de pudeur parce
que je vous parle
sexuelle il ya bien d'autres formes de
jouissance d'ailleurs l'exemple jeu
quand je vous dis que la jouissance et
du plaisir prendre du plaisir à avoir du
plaisir être un jouisseur dans ce sens
ça s'applique en bien des domaines donné
prendre du plaisir à goûter un bon vin à
écouter une bonne musique à regarder un
tableau le plaisir privilégier le
plaisir c'est une façon une manière
d'être
mais encore une fois il ya la forme la
façon de le libérer
est ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur et
c'est là où je veux en venir c'est club
parce que la jouissance unanime en
serait pas toujours une forme de mystère
et que la difficulté que nous avons en
parler c'est que nous pouvons jamais la
nommer telles quelles leçons qui avait
ouvert ce moment sur d'autres lots ceux
d'entre vous qui l'auront kg - reconnu
c'est être connu la boîte mail ryan dans
quand harry rencontre sally sont le
personnage de meg ryan et face à crystal
donc arriver face à salies et harry se
vante de conduire toutes les femmes que
je rencontre avec qu'il se retrouve au
lit jusqu'à l'orgasme jusqu'à la
jouissance à l'issue du match dont tu
peux être sûr de ça et qui n'attend que
ça ne soit ça ne trompe pas il ya des
signes extérieurs la jouissance ne
trompent pas ah oui dit elle
et c'est là où elle se met à simuler un
orgasme en plein milieu du restaurant là
venez de l'entendre
impossible de savoir quand on entend le
son s'il s'est agi d'une jouissance
réelle ou non d'un orgasme real ou non
parce que c'est pas la même chose on
peut jouir sans orgasme un orgasme
conduit pas forcément la jouissance
je préfère de sondages rassurez vous je
pense que l'expérience personnelle
parlent d'elles mêmes voyez à quel point
c'est délicat justement à quel point
cette subtile et c'est de définir ce
qu'on entend par jour sans
si c'est l'art de conduire le plaisir
jusqu'à sont jusqu'à son terme jusqu'à
une forme de fin mai cette fin elle est
toujours provisoire
elle renaît sans cesse le jouisseur et
celui qui sait aussi faire renaître de
ses cendres le désirent parce que la
france n'est jamais que provisoire or ce
qui m'intéresse dans cette question en
particulier c'est que de ce mystère il
ya la jouissance à savoir que c'est je
pars ministère c'est presque un drame
on ne sait jamais si l'autre joue mais
par jouir j'entends jouir prendre du
plaisir à avoir de plaisir on le sait
pas et bien de ce mystère on en a fait
quand je dis les hommes en ont fait
l'apanage du film l'autre dans la
jouissance c'est toujours la femme
le mystère de la jouissance a toujours
le mystère de la femme pour des raisons
anatomiques très clair ceclad d'un point
de vue purement sexuelle l'anatomie des
hommes fait que bien le plaisir et
beaucoup plus apparent que chez la femme
mais comment de cette différence
anatomique at on pu en conclure une
différence de nature de l'âge les sens
pourquoi parce que la jouissance pour
boîtes du constat que la jouissance n'y
est plus difficile à observer
on en a déduit qu'elle était non
seulement absolument autres absolument
mystérieuse mais infiniment supérieur
c'est un mythe
au sens propre du terme allait mettre à
mort aux deux vides en ondes le
personnage de tirésias qui est aveugle
j'en apprends les raisons à ces sites
est ce qu'un jour jupiter et junon après
un moment de détente ou lie de tension
puis de despentes discuter jupiter vie à
son épouse une honte mais je jeu j'en
vis ta volupté j'envie la capacité
infinie que tu as à jouer comme on peut
se dire papa qu'est ce que tu en scène
par définition on ne sait jamais comment
l'autre joue et 10 mai mais c'est
évident c'est évident je le vois je l'en
au temple tous les deux n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord et donc ils vont
consulter tirésias parce que tirésias a
eu l'occasion pendant sept années de sa
vie de vivre dans le corps d'une femme
c'était une punition il a interrompu un
coït entre observant les dieux pour le
punir l'ont transformée en femme pendant
sept ans au bout de sept ans il a vu
sortir de sa punition en reprenant le
même geste et cette fois ci leurs
revenus sommes donc lui seul fait c'est
le premier transgenre de l'histoire un
style signale donc lui seul sait à quoi
ressemble la jouissance masculine
akouala ressemble la jouissance féminine
jupiter et jus nouveau donc le consulter
tirésias dit mon arme l'expérience cette
année quand même j'en ai conclu que la
jouissance féminine infiniment supérieur
et la jouissance masculine suite à quoi
le juno après avoir entendu ces propos
le punit à nouveau et cette fois ci en
lui retirant la gym ma question la
question à laquelle personne n'a jamais
retenue est celle de savoir pourquoi jus
nous punit tirésias est ce parce qu'il a
révélé le mystère de la supériorité de
la jouissance féminine et qu'elle lui
offre parce qu'elle voulait que ça reste
un mystère
une espèce
de l'absence de conclusion sur la
question bien parce que elle même si
longtemps femme d'un âge où c'est pas
vraiment pas bien ou même pas du tout et
qu'elle en voulait attirer cias de
reproduire un mythe qui en fait lui nuit
il n'est qu'une étiquette que l'on a
cole sur la jouissance féminine
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
s'il ya une différence entre la
jouissance masculine la jouissance
nominal et c'est une vraie question
pourquoi faudrait-il genre et de la
jouissance
si on part du principe que c'est un
mystère et c'est une expérience
absolument subjective et impartageables
alors certes un homme joue différemment
d'une femme mais une femme ne veut pas
de la même façon qu'une autre femme et
un homme tue pas la même façon qu'un
autre homme il ya absolument aucun sens
à genre et la jouissance est pourquoi à
partir de là donc est ce qu'on a voulu
en déduire une espèce de supériorité de
la jouissance féminine et bien parce que
les rares personnes qui ont jamais pensé
la jouissance
certains l'ont fait les psychanalystes
lacan pour ne pas le nommer fait de la
femme le grand aux autres c'est toujours
l'autre l'altérité et cette femme farce
le féminin dit il qui n'est pas
forcément l'apanage de femme savait
le féminin et masculin sont deux
composantes qu'on peut retrouver dans un
corps de femme qu'on envoie comme d'un
gordon bien les plus mode de nommer
l'autre la femme est bien temps de
d'identifier cette altérité au mystère
lui-même de la jouissance de la
jouissance on n'aura jamais la clé parce
que la femme c'est toujours l'autre et
ce dont on ne sait jamais à quoi renvoie
la jouissance n'est que l'aveu n'ont pas
de l'impuissance de penser ce que la
jouissance
on y arrive très bien finalement
l'instrument une histoire et ils sont
forcément rentrer dans des détails
d'expériences personnelles mais
peut-être l'incapacité à penser une
expérience sont forcément black et sur
cette expérience des étiquettes du genre
bac samedi on ne voit pas les choses
elle même mais on voit les étiquettes
qu'on a posés sur elle c'est une phrase
très forte qui s'applique à tous
soit vous pouvez penser on ne voit pas
les choses elle même on voit pas les
personnes dans leur singularité ne voit
jamais les événements dans leur
singularité ont plein catégorie par
facilité pour mieux penser il ya en cas
de la jouissance le mist soi-disant
mystère de la jouissance est forcément
féminin parce qu'il est plus commode
pour le haut qui pensent qu'on ne sait
pas de quoi est fait la jouissance est
second jusqu'à il ya très peu de temps
et exclusivement masculin est plus
commun de dire que la femme c'est
l'autre or la jouissance c'est ce qui
nous échappe c'est l'autre que nous
essayons de nous approprier alors qui
nous échappe sans cesse c'est donc cet
autre sera forcément féminin et de là la
conclusion absurde eux la supériorité de
la jouissance féminine et pourtant si on
avait la preuve ce soir est ici
présentes
la femme s'est pas toujours loto merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une
oh oh oh je me sens comme un mât